I seek place of worship has become under
attack in Afghanistan's capital Kabul at
least four people have been killed the
interior ministry says unknown gunmen
and suicide bombers are targeting the
religious complex security forces have
cordoned off the area and have rescued a
number of hostages
Victoria Fontan is a professor of Peace
Studies at the American University and
Afghanistan joins me now
on skype from Kabul good to have you
with us on the programming the Taliban
are claiming that they're not
responsible so it's not them who could
it be
well it is most likely to be the Islamic
state in Khorasan or whatever they call
themselves they have a history of
targeting minorities in Afghanistan they
have targeted the Shiite minority in a
bombing of the wedding hall last August
and so it is most likely to be them
today so in terms of the attack I mean
what's the aim of attacking another
minority group normally we've seen
historically the Hazara minority group
being hit both in the capital and beyond
the Sikh community we rarely hear of
that sort of attack we really hear about
them but this is an overall mandate and
when we take and let's say policy from
the Islamic state to actually to
actually terrorize and antagonize all
minorities in Afghanistan from their
perspective it is supposed to be a Sunni
state and a caliphate and therefore just
like any other minorities in Iraq or in
other parts of the world they are being
targeted for the purification of what
they believe could become their
caliphate Afghanistan is currently
experiencing a political vacuum the
impact of that always seems to fall upon
security and as a whole the public
continue to worry about this of course
the public is exasperated by the
political games that are taking place at
the moment and they do want the
government and the state to actually
fulfill their responsibilities to them
and this goes with security but this
also goes with public health everybody
here is
expecting a tsunami to to happen and
they really don't know which government
is going to support them in this we
should see what does happen there for
the moment Victoria font and in Kabul
thanks very much for your time